Time to check out what
we've got loaded up.
Let's open up the project pane by
clicking the tab at the top left,
or by hitting Cmd+1 if you're on a Mac.
By default the project pane
only shows the source and
resources that are relevant
to an Android build.
That can be nice sometimes, but
for now let's use the drop-down
at the top of this pane to
open up the project view.
There we go.
Now we can see all the files and
directories in our project directory.
Let's open up the settings.gradle file.
This shows us all the modules
that make up this project.
Looks like this build has desktop,
Android, iOS, and HTML modules.
So that's where the code for
each of those specific platforms lives.
Then there's also the core module.
That's where we'll write the code
that will run everywhere.
Not all of these files and folders
will be super relevant to you, but
I want to go over what
all of them do just so
that there's nothing that
seems magical in here.
First the .gradle folder.
Gradle is a very smart build tool.
And when you ask it
to compile something,
it checks to see if it's
already compiled that file.
And if so, it says that that compilation
task is up-to-date and skips it.
The .gradle folder is where gradle
caches that sort of information.
The .idea folder is where Android Studio
holds its information about the project
and the state of the workspace.
It's just a ton of complicated
XML you don't need to touch.
We already talked about the android,
core, desktop, html and ios folders.
Then there's the gradle folder.
The gradle folder,
works together with the gradlew and
gradlew.bat files to form what's
called the gradle wrapper.
Basically, the point is, that gradle
knows how to download itself, so
you can version control what
version of your build tools your
actually building the project with.
It's something super fancy
you don't need to touch, but
it's also why you didn't have to install
gradle in order to build this project.
Pretty, cool, right?
The .gitignore file tells git which of
these files shouldn't be checked into
version control.
These consists mostly of files
that are user specific settings,
like everything in the .idea folder.
And, of build outputs like everything
that's in each of the build folders
where gradle spits out its outputs.
gradle.properties and
local.properties store more
gradle specific configuration.
Finally, there's a README file that
explains all this in much more detail.
So, that's it.
That's all of the files
on a libGDX project.
Nothing really magical.